لاوكرانيا يد طويله باتت تمتد الى عمق
الاراضي الروسيه فتضرب اهدافا في موسكو
ومناطق اخرى كما تستهدف مطارات عسكريه
وقواعد واهدافا حيويه روسيه وحتى الكرملين
انها المسيرات الاوكرانيه من احداثها
استهداف مطار نوفورود ورغم اشاره الروايه
الروسيه في التصدي للمسيرات الاوكرانيه
المهاجمه للمطار ذكرت في الوقت نفسه ان
طائره عسكريه روسيه اصيبت جراء الهجوم
الذي نتج عنه ايضا حريق في احد المدارج
هذه الحادثه وغيرها تثير التساؤل بشان
فعاليه انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه من
رادارات ومنظومات تصدى
في نيسان ابريل الماضي تحدث نائب القائد
العام لقوات الفضاء الروسيه الى صحيفه
روسيه مشيرا الى ان قواتهم واجهه تحديات
فرضتها الضربات الاوكرانيه وان بلاده تخطط
لاصلاح قوات دفاعها الجوي بعد اكتساب خبره
جديده
لمواجهه انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو
بالارقام تحدث الجنرال الروسي عن اضافه 50
محطه رادار متنقله وطائره انذار مبكر من
طراز اي 50 تعمل على مدى 24 ساعه وتكثيف
انتاج نظام
rl
kmcرات لكن رغم هذا التكثيف وفق المسؤول
العسكري الروسي فان الواقع يشير الى ان
نسق الضربات الاوكرانيه وارتفاع مستوى
تهديدها ظلاف ازدياد بالنظر الى التقارب
الزمني وطبيعه ما يستهدف داخل الاراضي
الروسيه تمتلك روسيا منظومات دفاع جوي
عديده ابرزها منظومات ار ال كي ام سي وتور
ام وبوك وبنتسير وهي منظومات قريبه
ومتوسطه المدى وقادره على ضرب اكثر من هدف
في وقت واحد مثل الطائرات والمروحيات
والمسيرات وحتى الصواريخ
وهناك منظومات دفاع جوي بعيد المدى ابرزها
اس بارقامها التصاعديه من 200 الى 3400
واحدثها اس 500 حتى الان يبدو محدودا ما
تحدثه هجمات المسيرات الاوكرانيه من اضرار
وفق الروايه الروسيه لكن الثابته انه يفرض
تحديا حقيقيا امام الجيش الروسي فمع تكثيف
الاوكرانيين لاستخدام سلاح المسيرات تتوسع
امام القوات الروسيه جبهه الحرب وتثقل
مسؤوليه الحمايه والدفاع في الجبهات وداخل
روسيا نفسها